You told me in the commercial break
you wanted to,
you brought something.
Yeah, I did.
I feel bad.
I've never done your show before
and you were so good to come and do
the global initiative we do for university students
and I feel like a schmuck.
I've never done your show before.
(laughter)
And you had to come to my neighborhood to do it.
Yeah, I,
now that you bring that all up,
I'm kind of bitter about it all.
(laughter)
I was fine,
I hadn't even really you know,
and then you bring it up
and now I'm angry.
Here's what I did.
I know you like bobble heads
so I'll be a guest all the time now.
Oh look at that.
(applause)
The great thing,
(laughter)
the great thing about my bobble head is
you can turn it into a bad political joke
that every time you say something
you can just tump me on the head
and I'll agree with you every time.
(laughter)
Yep.
I got to put you
right there next to Eisenhower,
how's that?
Is that alright with you?
It's a good thing.
Yeah, different parties,
but both I think, you know--
(applause)
It's funny, you know,
it was a different world,
but a couple years ago,
in this scholar's rating of presidential
performance,
Eisenhower and I were back to back.
But I always
liked him
because
he ordered the integration
of Little Rock Central High School.
Yeah, yeah.
He federalized the national guard.
(applause)
Yeah.
And--
Very impressive figure.
It was a big deal in my childhood, you know,
that he,
he did that.
He had to call out,
he had to send in the 101st Airborne Division,
but he first nationalized the
National Guard to stop the governor
who had blocked nine black children.
We just celebrated the 60th anniversary of that.
Eight of them are still alive.
(applause)
They've had remarkable lives.
And,
it shaped my whole life.
So, when the chips were down,
he decided he believed in the constitution.
Yeah, yeah.
God bless him.
It's a good deal.